chef calls us outlaws but I say we are
free unlike some other Robin Hood's I
can speak with an English accent there
are countless examples of American
actors who do terrible British accents
I've seen many strange things already
Mary Poppins you look beautiful while
most British actors appear to have
perfected their American accents is that
the going rate for saving the woman you
love so why do Americans have such a
tough time I think part of it is an
illusion I think part of it is just the
fact that we actually hear a lot more
British actors doing American accent
Eric singer is a dialect coach based in
New York
how many accents and dialects can I do
all of them he works with actors to fine
tune their accents for film and TV I
think we could probably think of some
accents from British actors some
American accents that are their less
successful I can't imagine a world
without you guys you can hit and these
guys you came the British actors who do
really successful American accents tend
to live in the States tend to come here
and really be sort of aiming at the kind
of success that you know having a career
in TV and film that's produced in
Hollywood represents the American actors
who do really good British accents and
there are plenty tend to be under the
radar a little bit more you know they're
doing theatre in London or something
like that the type of training actors
receive can also come into play more
British actors tend to have a drama
school training in which speech and
accents and phonetics is part of it so
what are some examples of Americans who
can do a good British accent I've heard
some clips of Michael C Hall in the
Netflix series safe doing an English
accent it sounds really really really
good I'm eating for Jenny my daughter I
think she was with Chris last night is
she here Alan Tudyk does a great job
he's the the robot ends in rogue one I'm
a reprogrammed impure
droid on the flipside singer says there
are numerous British actors who have
really nailed their American accents
Idris Elba's kind of African American
accent and the why're you going out on
point picking up business in the pit
ain't nothin else to look
Daniel Kalu you did an amazing job I
think and get out a little bit they were
asking me by the African American
experience maybe you could take this one
mark Rylance his native accent is
english he usually does a really great
job in American accents hello I am James
Halliday if you're watching this I'm
dead for those who have struggled with
accents in the past need that money Tom
singer has some tips for actors looking
to hone their skills listen to a native
speaker listened a lot and listen some
more it's an act of the imagination
taking on another accent if you're not
familiar with the culture the place the
people or you don't have a strong kind
of sense of empathetic identification
that's when it gets really hard Meryl
Streep is famous for having done this a
lot and being surrounded by people who
talk in the target accent 1941 when
Japan attacked Pearl Harbor Meryl Streep
doing Margaret Thatcher which is a very
specific and idiolect it's one person's
accent but it's absolutely flawless when
doing a British accent there are a few
basic things to keep in mind
posture wise tongue tips tend to be
pointy ER jaw tends to be a bit higher I
would listen particularly for sounds
like goat the O sound words like hold
goal hope I tend to use a bit more pitch
tend to use pitch for emphasis a bit
more so that'll get you started there
are many types of British accents and
some tend to be more difficult than
others one thing that that comes up for
some reason that a lot of Americans seem
to really struggle with is Welsh accents
a lot of it is a lack of exposure it's
just like Welsh what does that even
sound like for a lot of Americans unless
you've gone to see a production of under
mill code or something like that you
probably haven't been exposed to lots of
Welsh accents there's also one type of
British accent that actors tend to lean
on one of the first things that you'll
see a Mara
and actors do is kind of straighten up
yes and I've got to be like this and
there's an association with a kind of
fanciness sometimes you'll see a British
actor is kind of get soft and floppy and
lean back because Americans are all like
that which is adding a particular
character in attitude on top of an
accent and I think it's really important
not to rely on those sorts of things and
to realize that that people are people
and character is to a large extent
independent of accent to perfect an
American accent you need to focus on one
key letter a huge thing is getting
American our sounds and there's two
things that can be challenging there one
of them is just making sure they're all
there in unstressed syllables like at
the ends of words like other another
mother sister brother you know writer
Baker we tend to skip right over those
American ours usually are made for most
people with the sides of the time kind
of bunching up it's a really odd thing
to do with your tongue and it can feel
very awkward and clumsy it involves a
lot of muscularity regardless of your
skills sometimes your true accent will
pop up unexpectedly getting very
emotional
yelling also being tired or drunk these
are times when accents do tend to slip
kill Bethany my old girlfriend with a
nail gun
so how long does it take to master an
accent it just depends it really does
the more time the better if you have six
weeks before shooting starts or before
rehearsals start for a play and you work
on it really really hard ideally with a
really qualified dialect coach you know
you stand a pretty good shot of getting
to a good place yes sir I will give it
my full attention our work is finished
here has just begun
[Music]
you